we ran away
very spontaneously in our group
where the parents communicate with the coaches
, a message appeared that we urgently needed to
get together today there was an opportunity
to leave,
I didn’t want to go, but my husband persuaded me
because
my family had a budget from the Gamma war for the second time, we
drove 56 hours,
well, it seemed that we got  here is
an old film about the Second World War, we
were driving in the background in the dark, as
my husband later explained to me, this is done specifically
for security purposes, because if an
enemy plane flies and he sees lights,
he can simply start a bombardment,
arguing that the military can also move in the composition
equipment,
well, children shouldn’t endure this at
that age,
we received us very well, but we are extremely
grateful to the
local residents all over the country of latvia for
receiving
us for a long time, the
Latvian drivers waited more at the border,
they also waited for us for 6 hours, they didn’t
understand in general where we would arrive and  we
ourselves did not know where we would
be taken when we were brought from  we were also very warmly
welcomed,
fed, put to bed, and they try to
take care of somehow everything we need to help
thanks for our children
but provided training that they
continue to practice their favorite
sport of basketball, but we literally
feel this warmth from every city dweller we meet  it’s
worth it, really, mum c, not
even any attention, but I’m walking there with my
daughter, a person can just come up
there, give candy without
saying anything, that is, well, everything is clear from the
looks,
thank you very much